Wow.
Oh,
well go to your mom's house.
Christina
told me
Baba skunk number two by Ross.
Dude,
Dean English.
You're going to say Louis tits?
I'm Derek.
Yeah.
September 22nd and 23rd at helium comedy club.
Definitely not la,
but I've never been to Saint Louis tits of you many times.
What should I eat there?
Uh,
you gotta have,
they always have pork sliders.
What they're known for.
Kelby eating that October 3rd nourished Ville tend to tend to tits.
Yup.
10 tits xannies calm club.
October 4th shirtless North Cara,
Kyle,
Kyle liner,
the comedy zone.
And then October 8th with my gene.
Live at your mom's house.
Live in sperm,
vine,
California.
And that's it until 2018 guys,
Mama likes to take the holidays at home.
You know what I'm saying?
Holler at your boy.
September 27 two shows in Albany at the funny bone.
First one sold out.
Second one only had like 30 tickets left.
So by the time you hear this,
I don't know what's left the next day.
Redding,
Pennsylvania,
the a Santander performing arts center.
The next day,
the State Theater,
uh,
September 29th in Portland,
Maine.
And the end,
the week at the big old Sony Center for the Performing Arts in Toronto,
Ontario,
Canada,
Mark Jfl 42.
Okay.
Stereo.
It's the province.
I'm fine.
That is a province you're from.
Um,
and I go,
yeah,
from there I'm home for a little bit and then I go to Ann Arbor Indian Apple
tits and the hard rock hard cock.
Yeah,
I was going to say,
come see.
No.
And Northfield just outside of Cleveland,
Ohio.
I go to St Louis tits then later in October.
Oh,
you do?
Yeah.
And then Fargo,
North Dakota,
North Dakota.
So I've not been there,
but I like the TV show.
It's fantastic in the movie.
Um,
so yeah,
that's that.
I'm very excited.
And go to Tom [inaudible] dot com slash tour or go to Christina p online.com.
That's its new identity with my special dropping Christina p.
It's universal.
October 10th,
October 8th
I podcast.
Tom Cast.
Um,
all right gene,
a lot to get into.
Let's get the show on the road.
Here we go.
Well,
this is new tonight.
A family has had enough.
They say a woman is defecating on their sidewalk near Briar Gate and union in
Colorado Springs.
The family says they've caught her in the act twice now they've begged her to
stop,
but now springs police are getting involved.
Christina pushes,
it's increased
the mad hooper.
Colorado Springs is good.
I thought for a second when I heard this story that it was you who?
Oh cause I was in Denver,
Colorado.
Yeah.
I thought it was you.
What are you talking about?
This is a very handsome news reporter.
What?
She's a very handsome woman.
Why do you say that?
It's kind of like,
it looks like a dude with a Bob Haircut,
right?
Like legit.
Is it a transgender?
No,
that's not.
Why are you doing that?
That's not nice,
but here's why I'm being a jerk about this stuff.
Because if you work in television,
you should be attractive,
Babe.
God,
your vicious.
Sometimes it's the truth.
I demand the same excellence from the males too.
Just so you know.
What's Your Pronoun?
Well,
there you go.
I'm,
I'm harsh around the guys.
Believe me actually.
She really is.
Especially the old hound basset hounds.
I am on Morley safer.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's dead.
Yeah.
I think he died the week after he retired.
He retired and then he died like a week later.
Maybe a month.
Yeah.
Got To work right up until the end.
Huh?
I know it is funny because you are the first person to point that out to me and
I'd never thought about it.
So one of those things you don't think about where you would walk by the TV and
you'd be like,
ah,
they allow this guy on TV and I'd be like,
what?
And you're like,
he's so ugly.
They would never let a woman like that on TV.
And then I was like,
I started to,
the more you think about it as you watch TV,
if you,
if you've never thought about it,
think about it now and you're like,
that's definitely true.
That dude looks like a dog.
Shit.
It's hot dog shit.
All Dog Shit.
And if you look at,
especially in the sports world,
like now my God works is that they got these cuties down on the ground
interviewing the coaches and they're hot,
they're hair's all curled and tendrils and they've got the,
the other thing I did short skirts.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
The little hotties on the sidelines,
that's uh,
that's been a phenomenon for the last 15 years or so.
The,
um,
and like,
yeah,
sometimes you're like,
does she really?
Is she really,
does she understand sports?
Cause I assure as some of them really,
really sure.
But then you got the Basset Hound gang that's a,
the ESPN guys after I've talking about the game for five hours and you're like,
these guys look like Shit,
look like shit.
Yeah.
Thing is,
uh,
their dad jokes.
I,
how would I even get into the point of unbearable,
just accepting their humor,
like being like,
oh,
that's part of it.
And now I judge it more harshly.
Like these fucking tools making their terrible jokes.
And they're like,
right,
like look like a Scott,
what he's doing right now.
And then they're like,
oh.
And they act like it's really bad about that.
And especially because they can hire comedy writers,
doesn't it?
There's no shortage of funny people in the world to write for years.
Supposedly locker room banter like them just be in guys.
But a lot of it's super late.
Terrible.
Yeah,
I can agree.
I Wa I don't even watch it with you.
That's your one.
That's I would say the one thing you and I really don't share as a hobby.
This is football,
but I'll walk.
No,
I'll walk into the room and I'll hear some stupid joke and you can have separate
interests,
you know,
of course.
No,
I know.
I'm just like,
I feel like some people are like,
you know,
the whole,
we do everything together.
We're not together.
No,
we're,
we're a bonded pair.
That means we knew everything.
Jump into the fact that,
I mean,
obviously this young lady,
uh,
is a Colorado and uh,
be,
uh,
we were there.
Uh,
I shot a special this weekend and a Denver and mom for Colorado and there was an
awesome,
awesome experience.
Great night.
Thank you to everybody that came out.
I even added a show the night before at comedy works and that was really fun.
I was so scared going into the week because I was sick.
The sickness that you know here in Christina's voice.
Thank you.
Uh,
and I was anxious man,
because you know,
you're going into a taping and you don't feel good and you're coughing your
throat doesn't feel right.
And nasal drip.
I mean it was,
it was terrifying.
I mean I really had anxiety about it,
not about the show,
just about being sick,
you know?
And thankfully the day of the Sh,
the night before the show,
if I,
honestly I had considered canceling that comedy works show cause I was like,
what am I doing?
You know,
I'm taping tomorrow,
I don't feel good.
I'm doing another show.
I don't need to do this show.
But I was like,
I'll just do it.
And I did it and then I was like,
I'm going to bed.
And I got some Nyquil,
took my meds and I got good sleep.
Like,
I got solid,
you know,
eight hours or something or I woke up and I was like,
I don't feel like absolutely dragging.
Like I'm exhausted right now.
And that put me in a good mental place that like I got good rest.
I was still sick,
but I was,
I was coming out of it,
you know,
like I still right now I just have like the lingering last effects of it.
But I had the,
I had the,
you know,
the thought like,
Oh okay,
I'm well enough to get through and then you arrived.
And um,
I got,
I got sick before I came and that right.
But I'm saying when you got there,
we were like,
no,
let's just get in bed.
So we got in bed,
turn the lights off again.
This is why we're married.
Yeah.
And we,
and we tried to,
I think we slept for like another half hour or something like that.
And then we got lunch and then it was like,
okay,
like the routine,
you know,
the day is getting going and we just kind of,
we eased into it.
We just took it easy.
Yeah.
And then that night,
I mean that was nuts,
right?
Like those crazy,
you know what I didn't realize because I haven't been going with you on these
shows,
like I've just been only hearing about them because we don't travel together
anymore because of the kid really is how many fucking people where they're like,
you've told me the numbers and then until you see like a theater of people who
are so geeked to be there and these people were so pumped,
it was so fun.
I was like,
oh my God.
Like how are you this normal?
Like if that were me,
I'd probably just be freaking out.
Like I'm like,
they're going to hate everything.
Wait,
why do you say that part?
I just have a negative self talk.
But you,
I feel like how does it not make you like an unbearable egomaniac?
I,
I'd be like,
I don't know how how you deal with it.
It's normal.
I mean,
God,
there's so many people here.
I'm not an unbearable that you go maniac to begin with and you're not,
it's not your nature,
but you do.
You do dislike people.
I mean somewhat,
somewhat,
but I mean,
I like,
he goes funny.
I was like,
we talk about things on this show.
Like I always make jokes about like I don't like crowds and I don't like,
I don't want to fucking,
you know,
I have,
I've had jokes in my act like I'm all friended up and all this stuff and when
you say those things in your act and you talk about it,
then people end up like people,
I meet people after shows and they go,
I know you don't want to meet me right now.
I know this is your least favorite part of this.
And I'm like,
no,
because it's always super nice people.
Yeah,
of course.
I'm like,
that's not what I'm talking.
I'm talking about just the masses,
you know,
like loud,
nondescript.
I think people individually are great.
It's the crowds where you're,
you don't know what will make you hate people going to an NFL game,
all blues and the Broncos game.
And like you're just seeing,
I mean there's great people at the game,
but there's just the loud of noxious drunk scumbags that Phil every NFL stadium
and you're like,
oh my God,
can they just put these people down?
There should just be a scumbag area where like if you want to be drunk and
annoying,
go there.
You know what I was,
I was amazed by that show.
The restraint that I saw these,
like they're throwing a guy out and he was wearing a purposely gigantic
oversized cowboy hat.
Oh boy.
And uh,
he was a cowboys fan cause the cowboys were playing the Broncos and uh,
him and his friends were getting tossed out and he was just like,
to these guys,
he's like,
fuck you,
you fucking pigs.
And I was like,
who in society does that?
Like who scumbags,
right?
Like we were just watching and I'm like,
hello.
How out of your mind are you?
Like,
you're like,
suck it,
you fucking pigs to that to like to cops and cops don't police case.
Yeah.
Like he's,
and he's like,
you fucking,
and like double the double birds.
I like pointing to his Dick,
fuck you,
you piece of shit.
And then they're kind of slowly walking towards like very calmly and they're
like,
and then he kept backing up and he had this giant oversized hat on,
like not a regular cowboy hat.
It's like purposely enormous.
And then I look over at other cops in the,
in the car and they're looking and they're like smiling.
And I was like,
you sitting there like,
you know,
we see him,
we see him like your life sucks and then you're going to take it out on the
police at the game.
Yeah,
you got a football game.
We do want to get out on them.
That's why People Act Fools in public.
Right.
They can't control their lives and they get out in public and they,
they're going to control this.
Right.
I'm going to know you.
I'm going to show them that.
As much as I like football,
as much as I like football,
every time I go to a game,
I regret going to a game.
Yeah,
well cause it's the,
it's the uncontrolled masses.
As a collective,
we suck as humans.
I think I would like to go to a game if I could get a field pass.
Well let me call him,
stand on the sidelines for the simple fact that I would love to watch football
live and not be near another human being.
You can't,
you get like super private boxes.
Yeah,
I've done boxes.
I,
I'm conflicted about boxes.
Boxes are really like,
it's a,
I guess it's kind of the,
it's,
it does isolate you and it's kind of a luxury.
It's nice,
it's nice.
But,
um,
no,
it's good perspective.
You know,
like you,
you see the game,
but I feel kind of removed from it.
I mean,
you know,
like when you go to like whatever a high school game,
you can,
you can walk on the sideline or like close to it.
You know,
I like,
I like being like down on the field.
I do like it and I know you can get that.
I've talked to some people about getting a field pass to a game before and
they're like,
yeah,
we can arrange that.
But I mean it's,
you know,
it's not like you can,
you go on stub hub and be like,
feel past.
It's like you have to,
you have to make it to be special.
You have to make calls.
Um,
yeah,
I liked that.
I liked it.
You're out about hating people.
I liked that you out at me on this show about being an La Snob and how you hate
everywhere.
Everywhere.
That's not home.
It's not la La.
I don't even give a shit.
My favorite part about that for you though,
cause I kind of feel this way a little bit too,
is um,
everybody feels free to shit on la.
Like it's like,
uh,
you know,
and so a lot of times people are like,
when I meet them,
they're like,
where do you live?
Oh,
I live in La.
They're like,
I can't stand it.
And I'm like,
we're,
we're the fuck do you live?
And then they,
you know,
they list wherever Toledo or something.
I'm like,
is that great?
And they're like,
I like it.
I'm like,
yeah,
I like where I live to fuck you.
Right.
That's kind of how I feel about it.
It's not that I think la is better than everywhere else.
It's familiar.
No,
I don't like unfamiliar.
I would like to correct you.
You think La Better?
It's better for me because it's familiar to me.
I'm like,
I know that you're a better,
worse places to live in the world.
What's great about being home?
It's home and like,
I like my nice weather.
I don't care about the traffic.
It doesn't bother me.
I don't fucking care about celebrities doesn't bother me.
I like it when people go,
I can't do all that Hollywood stuff.
I'm like,
what are you,
what?
Don't worry about it.
You won't have to.
Uh,
I like Avocados.
I like fresh produce oranges and stuff that aren't gray.
Well,
once you,
I mean gray bananas.
That's what I see on the east coast.
When I go to these places like buffalo or Syracuse,
whatever,
it's all gray.
Bananas.
Fucking getting your bananas from Dude,
come to California and Shit's all yellow here.
Fucking bro,
Bro.
He has don't even know what an avocado looks like.
I've been in parts of this country where they have not even seen an avocado
fruit.
Ain't the right color man shit from Mexico.
Dude.
Wait,
can we talk about this pooper?
Yeah,
we can,
but I also wanted to one last,
um,
I mean I really wanted to say it meaningfully.
Thank you to everybody in Denver because that was,
that was a thrill for me to shoot a special in a city that I've,
I know I've always told you I love Denver.
I do.
And you guys came out and the shows were fucking there are so fun.
It's going to be such a great special and I'm really excited for people to be
able to see it on Netflix.
Right.
Do we have an ETA on when it may drop?
People keep asking me.
I mean they haven't told me that all park,
they'll give me a ballpark.
I know that typically they do to three to four month turnaround.
Yeah.
But sometimes they change it up,
so we just don't know.
That's true.
Because I fill mine in June and then it's dropping in October.
Right on that schedule.
So there you go.
So around there.
Um,
all right,
so there's a lady pooping and calling things,
but the altitude gets me every time and mom or I'm very sensitive to it.
Yeah,
yeah.
That was a fun and stuff.
It does.
Spencer,
this is so gross.
So gross.
You've ever heard somebody say that?
According to the buddy family about once a week,
they're getting all too familiar with the paper towel.
She wipes with nasty surprise.
She leaves,
she nasty.
She's so nice to take off that one piece.
SPANDEX,
she's wearing a one piece units,
right?
That means she's got a strip completely naked to take a shit.
So she's getting down to titties.
She crazy as hell.
Right?
Extra crazy.
Kathy Buddy and her family have had enough
and it's not like it's private.
People can see you.
I mean we're saying hers
pants around her ankles in broad daylight.
Her kids saw it happened first.
They come screaming and you know,
you're not going to believe this.
They were like crying.
It's like quiet.
And they're like,
there was a lady taking a boat and so I came outside.
I was like,
Oh dear goodness.
And so I was like,
are you serious?
Are you really taking a poop right here in from my kids?
And she's like,
yeah,
sorry.
Just,
yeah,
sorry.
She didn't have an excuse.
Like I have diarrhea,
I can't find a bathroom.
Like it's clearly a runner so I could get,
if you're like,
oh this happened,
you know,
like I,
I panicked this emergency.
But it doesn't sound like that's what's happening.
Cause running makes you have to poop.
Yeah,
but I mean that's what I'm saying.
Like in the running I've done,
I've still never had to be like,
oh my God right now,
right here I have to go.
I'm like,
maybe this lady has a bowel problem,
like an abs thing.
But listen to this though,
Kathy says,
if that was it,
there wouldn't be a problem.
I thought for sure she's mortified it was an accident.
She'll go get a dog bag,
come back,
clean it up and never run here ever again.
I'm not the case.
Kathy says the runner knows what she's doing and comes with Napkins and her
pockets
and nasty.
Here's the other thing,
Nancy.
Jesus.
This is why I have a theory.
There's a bathroom across the street right here.
Um,
our park has port-a-potties.
there's a gas station right here.
She's even working on an embarrassing smear campaign,
posting this sign to get her to cut the,
well,
you know,
cut the
local news.
Uh,
this lady is totally getting off on shitting in public.
That's,
this is the equivalent of a man who pulls his dick out.
You know,
it is,
it's a sexual arousal necessarily section.
There's a thrill.
There's some type of thrill going on.
She likes,
she likes taking a dump in public,
wiping it there either people seeing her and going like,
are you really doing this?
And she's like,
Yep.
Or discovering it.
She gets a thrill out of doing it.
I can see it actually,
now that I know you explained it that way,
I could see myself doing that and getting,
wait,
that's not supposed to know.
Well,
because it's sneaky and now that she knows they're on her escalate and you have
to now it's a real challenge.
Like,
no,
she's,
she knows she's doing a naughty,
bad and dirty thing.
Yeah,
she's breaking the law and it's just a matter of time before they catch her
though.
It is.
I mean there's going to wait for her or can they just wait for her?
Oh yeah.
She definitely,
any buck people that watch this in that community.
I'm sure they probably have pegged her by now,
I'm sure.
What's the penalty for shitting in front of?
Well,
they're going to,
they're going to Trump up some charges.
Well,
the charge
public indecency.
Me Probably.
Yeah.
That's disgusting.
Bottom line is this discussed really,
officers have asked Cathy to snap some pictures of the runner and get the word
out hoping she was stopped before.
Indecent exposure with deprecation charges.
Public deprecation,
not a natural thing we would do in our society.
It is drop your trouser and relieve yourself when you know there's people
around,
especially like to be more natural with my name.
I'm thinking shit.
Then taking a shit on your face,
Kathy,
you let me know she's had other people come forward and say that they have the
same thing happening to them.
They've seen that woman relief herself outside of a Walgreens and in people's
back yards.
Know who she is.
Police would love to hear from you and you sell it back to you.
It's clearly a thing now.
Yeah,
she's,
she's done it in front of Walgreens.
They get shits,
man.
I mean,
that's her thing.
Let her do it.
Oh,
the big deal is,
uh,
no,
she's,
that's foul man.
And she's shitting in front of people's kids.
Like you're fucking nasty as hell.
It's disgusting.
So disgusting.
I don't know.
There's worse crimes in society here.
I was definitely worse crimes,
but like human shit is so early and it's harsh.
She's taking a runner's shit.
It's,
that's so funny.
You know how many of my friends sent this to me,
by the way?
Yeah.
Like all of them.
They know.
They know what the show's about,
man.
They know what it's about.
This is so gross.
This is so grow,
grow.
I like when they use the dynamat paper,
the technical word,
when you're like,
this woman is defecating and I guarantee you a lot of the people listening don't
know the word defecating.
Yeah.
Defecating isn't,
Americans would never guarantee a lot of them don't know slaves taking a shit
and for your fucking house,
Bro.
Have you heard that?
Um,
that I'm crazy.
He from Bill Burr.
Yeah.
Yes.
I've heard the rumor mill and a rumor.
What do you feel about it?
Of course.
What have I been making fun of you for?
For forever.
That laughing one that I shouldn't laugh.
Right?
Which means that you on some level it resonates with you.
What do you think of the wrong evil?
Okay.
Boy,
you're really quiet.
Sometimes when you stand next to him,
I just paid her into his head sometimes like what's going on in there?
And if you're a psycho,
you've,
you spot another cycle.
And it's just like,
this is a fucking movie going on there that I would love to finance.
You almost hospitalized me one time from laughing so hard.
Like,
I don't know if you remember,
this is 20 people for the first show and as a girl,
Joe Rogan,
that's a 12 with a guy that's a fault.
Said you're very beautiful.
And then she just went and ran with it and started talking to my husband.
Pimps are out.
No fights for 20 bucks.
You could fucking with the back of the room twice,
right?
I don't know.
This girl is beautiful and this we thought is just
showing between shows.
I talking to them about what's going on.
Oh my God,
I had such a great thought.
I think it was that stuff.
True.
As she goes.
Yeah.
I go show me the monkey in the woman's bathroom.
Pull down the pants.
The girl had a monkey that was spotless.
It nearly stunk.
I ate it.
I framed it up some and then she sucked my Dick.
That was it.
I went back to my room.
I didn't think nothing of it.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ.
She starts going,
no,
I suck.
The Canadians.
[inaudible] was like,
what are you talking about?
And she's like,
I suck this Dick.
And he kicked her by mouth.
He's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
The cops had to hold them back.
Lisa,
I want my $40 that's all he wanted.
Jesus,
you think that's crazy?
You're right.
The biggest bug is like shit.
I side with Joe and bill on this one.
You're out of your fucking mind.
Blue Band made that so props to blue band.
Wait,
what part of that story was funny for all of it?
The part that the woman's husband,
prostitutes or already to comics.
So funny.
Why are we no,
really,
I'm serious.
Why is it funny to you?
Like what part is the giggle?
It's like you're asking me like I feel like you're asking me what part isn't
funny.
Okay,
so that I don't know where to start.
What part is funny meal?
The whole thing.
Everything is funny about it.
It's funny the way he tells it.
It's funny that that that happened,
that that's a reality somewhere.
All of it's funny.
Okay.
That's funny story.
So don't you like funny stories?
I do.
I just don't.
I don't think that,
I think it's sad.
And what part of it's sad.
Bummed out for the girl.
Honestly.
She liked doing it.
Did she?
Yeah,
she was.
He was all about it.
That's what he said.
Why don't you cry at the end that she cried when she stuck around for the second
show and then he started,
um,
she realized like it Kinda hit her,
I guess when the drugs wore off or something and then she started crying.
But like,
it's funny that somebody would start crying and saying,
I suck that guy's Dick in a show.
I would laugh at that.
When you laugh at that,
like she just did it.
She volunteered to do it.
You wouldn't laugh at that.
Can you bring this up in therapy?
What about it?
Just bring it up.
You need to work on it.
I think it's,
you don't think it's funny?
No.
Why not?
Because it just isn't,
it's just not,
it's not like,
it's not on my radar is humorous.
It's like a story where I'm like,
sad.
I feel bad for that lady.
I laughed.
That's half as hard as I laughed the first time he told me that the first time
he told me that I seriously could have used an oxygen tank.
Okay.
I laughed so hard,
just like I left it,
that Wu Tang story about when they were sentenced by bill thinks you're a
psycho.
It didn't it start there.
Well,
I told him that story.
He did not,
he didn't laugh.
Yeah,
because bill and I have what's known as empathy.
You always say that bullshit.
Okay.
He's actually a really,
uh,
you know,
sweet guy.
I'm not like a tender,
but I'm not as we got cuddle bear.
You know,
you,
you are too.
But I do feel like you have these dark demons inside that you're not really
letting on,
but what do you mean the rage inside?
No,
and stuff like that.
I laugh at things that are inappropriate,
you know,
that I know as do I,
yeah.
Mental illness makes me laugh a lot.
Right.
I think that's,
that stuff's real funny.
You think that,
that there's no suitable critique of that quality.
It's just not as sadistic as like suffering.
Like what you're laughing at is that this woman,
I'm not even in the,
the story in your arm.
That's the difference is like I'm,
I'm basically laughing at like the guy with Tourette's because that's a silly
byproduct of mental illness and I was a little bit of a neurological disorder.
Um,
things that schizophrenia,
people say.
It's funny to me because it's just a byproduct of,
of mental illness.
But yeah,
you're laughing at true suffering.
The suffering that gives you the tickle.
Yeah.
Like this woman was drugged and then her husband pimps are out and then she gets
with Joey Diaz.
Okay.
And then during the shows,
shouts it out that I suck,
that guys dig in.
And what does her husband do to her?
He wants his $40.
He's not mad that she sucked his dick.
He's mad that he hasn't been paid.
Okay.
Yeah.
So the depravity.
I mean I,
I don't,
I can't believe I would have to explain what's funny.
I actually,
and I'm being like,
this isn't a steak or anything.
Like I genuinely don't know what's funny.
You know,
like it's sad and to pray for me.
It's sad that somebody says,
I don't know what's funny.
That's what said,
I'm serious.
I'm,
I am either humor,
I am so serious when I say it's sad to me that somebody is like,
I don't know.
Understand what's funny about that.
That's what's sad to me.
Cause even in Henry Portrait of a serial killer,
yeah,
I do get it.
Like he snaps the hookers.
Huh?
Ah Ha.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then the guy looks back and goes,
yeah.
That,
that look is funny.
It's the look that's funny to that crazy thing happening.
But I get the feeling that you're laughing at the hookers neck being snapped in
the first class.
I know it's the reaction.
We actually say it's the reaction,
the reaction.
And it's also that it's also that like,
um,
what's funny about that?
It's,
it'd be like if somebody was like,
hey,
these people need to shut up.
And then one of them goes and snaps her neck and you're like,
I didn't mean like that.
Right.
Like it's like one of those things,
you know,
like that is,
it's an extreme,
it's an extreme reaction to it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
But then I see it.
Then I feel empathy for the person who just got killed.
That's where I was not real.
It's a fucking movie.
You know.
What about the,
the Asian man that got his legs crashed
and he was screaming for help.
And a lot of people agree with me that that was hilarious.
A lot.
What was funny about,
about it that time that I'm,
what am I missing?
Oh my God.
Again,
it's like,
I feel like I'm explaining what's funny to my mom or something right now.
It's like,
I mean the look,
the sound,
the fact that the car kept coming back up,
the engines revving the guys.
Yeah.
You would know how to say words.
He's yelling and so much pain.
You got to bring this up.
What am I supposed to say?
Just,
I don't know dude.
Just explain this to him.
Yeah,
I'll be like a,
hey,
I want to talk to you about something that I laugh when super funny things
happen and um,
I don't understand why it's not super funny things.
It's super violent things,
silver,
inappropriately,
violent things that heart heart people.
I just think too,
like it's a little suspect.
You're just love of murder.
And like last night we'd watch a great movie together.
Baby driver.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Silly title.
Great movie.
And I'm like,
okay,
good night sweetie,
I love you.
I give you a kiss goodnight.
And then I just hear my bed,
think stab,
stab,
kill.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Can't fall asleep to this dude.
And you know,
and it's like another angry murder kill.
But I mean,
here's what's funny is nobody would listen to us and be like,
oh my God.
Like what kinds of thing are you watching?
Oh,
it's this little known series called Narcos on Netflix.
Okay.
So if it's not narcos,
it's usually like,
and the victim was a blonde woman,
a 41 year old mother of one son named Ellis.
They lived in a suburb of California.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
I gotta hear that stuff in the background.
What are you saying?
I'm going to murder you.
I didn't say you just did.
Is that what you're,
but that's what your fear is.
Feels like it.
Why?
Cause I watch shows.
No,
it feels like you do have some kind of repressed anger that's expressing itself
through your choice of humor and entertainment.
Like I have to tell you that I don't watch murder shows is free.
I don't,
I just never do not interested.
Not Interested,
because you're not the only,
like my mother's a type to go like,
Oh,
you just love these murder shows and then you have to go like,
Hey,
do you think that this murder show was made?
And they're just like,
I hope,
I hope just one guy watches it.
I mean,
you realize that millions of people watch,
okay.
Millions of people have mental problems and ideal
people also like these white bomber movies and medical dramas.
I don't like medical dramas.
Don't want to watch people with cancer.
Yeah,
no,
I'm the same way.
Fuck that.
So am I.
But I think that every night,
I mean it's okay.
It's like,
it's the same thing all the time.
Every night it's murder,
murder,
kill account account,
confessions of murders,
murders.
I like it.
It's entertaining.
Okay.
I would like to watch those shows or shows of people screaming cause they,
you know,
got hit by something or yeah,
I told you about that time I left uncontrolled Lena guys face when he told me a
bath tub was dropped on him.
Right.
I know they've heard it before.
I think I'm laughing that hard,
honestly,
if I were really break it down because it's so terrifying.
Maybe to me on a,
you know what I mean?
Like murder and these horrible
murder I'm talking about,
like when I laugh really hard,
it's so extreme to my psyche and I kind of fear it in such a way that it's how I
process what's going on.
In other words,
like when that guy told me that the bathtub was dropped on him and he was really
sincere and like told me what it did to him,
I think it wasn't like,
Oh,
I'm laughing at your misfortune.
It was like I couldn't look at him and process what was going on.
So I,
I had to laugh,
you know,
like I laughed to deal with it.
You know,
it's like laughing when you,
when you shouldn't laugh.
Yeah.
You can't handle the actual feelings about it.
I think I can't handle the actual feelings about even go there.
Oh,
that's what's happening.
Yeah.
Huh.
But that joy [inaudible] story is just funny.
That's just a funny story.
What inspired you to put this together within the Dov?
Oh,
I just thought it was funny that,
uh,
that I laughed really hard during that thing and that Joe was like,
now did Joe say anything at your ridiculous amount of laughter?
No.
I actually asked them afterwards I go,
I was laughing so hard at that and I looked at you and I saw you like with that
expression,
you're like,
I thought that you,
you know,
he was like,
oh,
I didn't,
I don't remember.
Like we were all smoking and drinking.
Sure.
He's like,
I'm going to remember that tissue,
please.
Yeah.
Well,
but I mean,
no,
no.
I thought it was fun
to put that together.
I don't know.
No.
Yeah.
Do you think I need help?
Please?
If you need help,
I get help.
I go everywhere.
Having a flashback of a beautiful detail snow removal off I did,
uh,
just north of here at a plateau last year.
I'll elevate it up like that.
Hey,
that fucker greeter has a plow in the front.
Wow.
That's fucking rare.
Yeah,
buddy.
That's fucking rare.
I'll look it up.
It's a snow plow dad boner.
Like you see how excited he got about that?
God's snow looks terrible.
Videoing a snow plow and he's like,
oh my God.
It has that feature that's fucking rare.
Oh my God.
I think that's an old fucking
Freightliner FLD from uh,
from the 90s.
Not a lot of those left around here.
It's running.
I mean,
oh yeah,
man.
There's my tongue nail right there.
Beautiful fucking Freightliner Murray.
Even,
I think I filmed that truck before in Saint Henry.
Oh,
he films it regularly,
right on.
Yeah,
man,
look at it sleeper on that.
That's a big rig man.
This guy's accent
from master of accents.
It's,
this was filmed in Montreal.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You know that baby wasn't made after 2009.
It sounds too good.
It is fucking snow plowing.
Yeah.
I mean this is definitely on the dad boner.
Sure.
Everybody has something you love killing and depravity and this guy likes snow
plows,
so,
okay,
well I'll tell you something guys.
This is definitely at first man.
Oh yeah.
I mean really,
I got the same team here to same company clearing the snow on this tree here,
which I don't remember what the hell it's called and they just did that side and
I got to do it again cause there was so much snow.
That's fucking weird.
It's actually two teams.
See,
look,
there's,
there's the other one is right there.
Super stoked about being,
his level of passion for snow plan is unlike so weird.
You kind of respect it though,
right?
You're like,
you really love this shit.
I mean everyone gets excited about something.
Yeah.
Like this is a,
I'm just marveling at the amount of snow that looks terrifying.
Yeah.
Yup.
Do you feel claustrophobic when snow falls like that?
Claustrophobic.
Yeah.
Like,
cause I didn't grow up in that.
Like do you feel,
I kind of feel claustrophobic.
Like it's,
I'm trapped inside.
Oh No,
no,
no.
You don't feel like,
oh my God,
the snow's going to take over.
It's no,
no,
no.
I kinda like it.
Yeah.
What,
what's the fun part?
Like,
what do you like?
I mean,
I don't experience it that more much anymore.
So it's a,
it's kind of a thrill and you know,
usually it's snowing,
I'm in a hotel or something.
I'm like,
oh,
I mean it looks beautiful,
cozy and stuff.
I like it.
Yeah.
I like the great thing about like extremes of weather.
Well,
you don't live in it is that I only experienced it for like 24 hours or
something.
Yeah.
Do you feel like not doing anything in that weather though?
Yes.
That's a thing.
I had weighed 200 pounds just cause I'd be like,
well,
I'm gonna make some potato soup.
Oh yeah.
That happens.
Yeah.
I don't want to go.
Why would you want to do is deuces out in Utah where it snows?
Yeah,
of course.
I would just order Postmates and like cozy up and watch some movies.
Yeah,
man.
Right.
Here's,
uh,
here's some,
some emails that came in.
I had to do.
Um,
we have a cell on my translation,
by the way.
Do Blind people save on electricity?
Yeah.
Hi.
Brilliant thought.
Provoker that's a good one.
So smart.
I had a thought while I was rub,
rub,
rubbing myself to sleep.
Do you think that blind people will save a shit ton of money?
Electricity?
See
you and peanuts and December,
Tom,
Armando,
I've never considered that.
But as soon as that thought hits your mind,
it's obviously you're like,
oh,
that makes total sense.
It's a silly question.
But then not because you're like,
well,
well they have to run like the standards.
You're heating or cooling your appliances,
but they don't turn the lights on.
At least I don't have to,
they don't have to write.
I mean,
depends on your level of blindness.
I've talked to some blind people that told me that,
you know,
there's,
there's levels obviously of blindness.
So there's,
there's people that actually are seeing shades and shapes and therefore like,
you know,
they sense light coming in that can effect,
where they see what their limited sight sees.
Of course.
Yeah.
And there's people that are totally 100% blind and I turned the lights on just
to prevent like burglars from assuming nobody's home.
Oh,
right,
right.
And that's just a safety measure and turn them on.
Well,
if thrilling question,
uh,
blind people,
let us know.
Yeah,
that's a really good one.
Do you want to hear,
I got a translation for so amazing.
Oh my God.
A Salamay.
Uh,
just to remind people had not left the,
uh,
or the message is for Sallie Mae had not been left in a long time.
And then,
um,
last week at a nowhere it happened again.
I know.
And,
and months,
months,
almost a year had gone by is that long since we moved here,
which was November of last year.
And we're almost in November,
so a little bit less than a year.
Unbelievable.
And I was so excited to hear it again.
I was just,
okay,
so,
so what did,
what was said?
So this guy writes in,
hi,
my name is [inaudible] from Los Gatos,
California.
Woo Woo blows.
God owes big fan of the show.
Translating what the uranium woman's said on your show.
Basically she's saying that you need to contact the termite company and for $450
they will come and treat your area and then she said put something white down on
the floors and they will find the termites.
That's pretty much it.
[inaudible] my name Jackson.
Why don't talk you down from Ima,
Timbo Cain book all Jacky Tran my day,
which was how the time they will do though.
My favorite part about the old Sallie Mae voicemails,
there was this guy,
they would translate a lot of them.
He told me,
he's like,
man,
it is so inappropriate for a woman that is obviously an older woman to talk.
The way she talks,
she's got her so he's like,
he's so vulgar.
She's saying things that like street guys say there's mother fuckers Salloway
yeah,
she talked a lot of Shit,
man.
She used to say that.
He's always giving a Salamay advice.
He's like,
you know,
put the put bags on the fruit tree is,
and you need to do this and this medicine,
pick it up from here.
Costs a lot.
And it must be a mother.
It must be a mother onto grandmother.
Some maternal figure in Salamis.
God,
this mystery.
I really wish we could find Salamat no.
Define Solomon.
Listen,
Persian community.
Can you please do some Intel like fucking ask people like there's obviously an
La Persian.
These are,
this is the number I believe in eight one eight Oh oh three went out asking the
La Community.
Find that blonde.
Amanda.
Let her know.
Well,
here's the thing,
you think that that's crazy.
But immigrant communities like in La,
there's a finite number of Hungarians in Los Angeles.
And if I talked to one Hong Go,
I'll be like,
hey,
do you know,
uh,
this guy auto?
He earns us the store in Burbank.
Yeah.
Well auto has got this daughter so and so.
Do you know her?
Yeah,
actually I do.
You can actually track it down.
Just like you found the kid,
the bikes kid,
you never know because of the interwebs.
So need detectives
detectives to get together and solve the Solomon.
Yeah,
somebody knows Salamay there's six degrees of separation here.
Absolutely true.
The world is much smaller now because of the interwebs course.
Salamay
I love it,
man.
So wait,
anything else anymore that we missed from that or no emails?
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying
that's it.
And he's like,
basically that's,
that's what's going on.
An email that came in on your Sydney's.
Hey guys,
it's Friday,
September 15th,
after countless hours,
long sleepless nights,
extreme night terrors,
keeping me from having a decent family life.
I would like to address the research I've been doing on Tina's sneeze.
Um,
if you listen very closely,
she's saying Jadah as she sneezes.
My theory on this cause is after being told many times that when I was younger
by my elders,
sneezing feels so good because you're getting all the bad out.
Then after hearing of genes,
longtime hatred of Jadah,
Pinkett Smith,
I've kind of the conclusion that much like a high number,
sloppy brown,
she couldn't control letting out what was to be a cry out of epic proportions.
He was obviously hurting inside and extruded jade,
his name and a last ditch effort to keep the demons out of her mind and off her
back.
I hope this helps and I hope I can get some sleep now.
It's been a rough month.
I was like,
couldn't get the sound out of my head.
Say High Tight and definitely stay non-binary and white.
Love Sky.
And I don't know,
it
sounds kind of like your second trade.
I don't hate,
I don't hate her.
Yeah.
I think I feel like,
I feel like she's in a marriage that is probably pretty wacky.
And then they got a wacky thing going on.
She and um,
well he just,
he slams everybody.
So what though?
And she's like,
well,
I'm Mrs. Smith.
I'm Mrs. Wilson.
I mean,
who?
Who cares what,
who cares that he's doing that?
So what I am not wired for that type of a marriage,
Tom.
Yeah,
I know.
But you're also not married to fucking Wellsmith like think about being married
to Willsmith.
I picture,
I picture myself married to will Smith and he's like,
uh,
I just,
whatever slammed a bunch of hoes,
I'd be like,
yeah,
yeah.
That's kind of what I signed up for it.
Your will Smith I guess.
So that level of celebrity,
you can't expect them to be international movie stars.
I mean,
I don't know that that,
I know he wasn't like a hardcore rapper,
but he was a rapper.
It's like,
yeah,
of course,
man,
you're going to fuck.
I guess that's the trade off.
I mean there are a lot of rich wives that that's what,
that's the game,
sign up for it.
That's the deal though.
Melania's of the world are like,
well,
I ain't going to suck this fucking trolls Dick.
But I think they like handbags.
They sign up when they go.
It's not a surprise.
Of course.
You're,
you're a hot piece of ass and yeah.
And he's a troll and he's got tons of,
well he's not even a wheel.
Smith's hot.
Yeah.
I don't know know what you're married.
I will be.
I couldn't,
I personally,
well,
yeah.
No,
but I mean that's not what I signed up for.
I'm a buyer.
We're in a bonded pair.
You and I were like a couple of Brussels,
no mannequin.
No,
I need my,
my knee,
my jeans.
Yeah.
Borrowing the parent when you're gone.
I'm,
I'm just,
I don't like it.
I'm not good.
Um,
uh,
let's see here.
I'm reading the Hay balers.
Have you guys ever wonder why old man flacid penises are always so big?
Yeah.
She always walk around locker rooms,
Butt ass naked,
Dick Swaying back and forth.
And you wonder,
is this because the more boners you get
so much that as an old man you have a bigger flacid penis.
My wife think is just the gravity of 80 years of your dick hanging there.
It makes it gradually bigger with age.
We need the help from the Dick Detectives,
keep it high and tight.
The Cox,
the gators,
Eric and misty from Nebraska.
Wow.
It's a really good question.
I have seen some big old sloppy decks in locker rooms and such,
but to be fair,
I've seen some small old Dick's too.
You know,
but I do know what he's talking about that it appears sloppier and sloppier and
sloppier and sloppier.
Because I mean,
I think both,
I don't think all the boners contribute to it,
but I do think gravity considering contributes to it.
The boner.
Yeah.
And some of them,
you know,
I mean,
some of them just have healthy hogs.
They're just,
you know,
it's just like any portion of the population.
But everything is sagging.
It's,
it's at your,
yeah.
We know we're biological beings that break down over time.
And I do think it's like you,
what you said,
just loose moose skin.
Loose meets.
Yeah.
Loose.
Everything.
Sags more,
everything.
My tits are a mass.
Everything's a mess.
But I've seen the little,
I've seen little on old guys,
little penis.
Yeah,
sure.
But even the skin doesn't get hanging on the little apartment.
Yeah.
The skin,
we'll head on it,
but it's still little.
But like,
you know,
it'll have like sloppy hang balls,
like big sloppy walls.
I think the balls are more effected than the Penis.
Uh,
for men,
male aging him.
If I'm not like I haven't seen,
I haven't seen many old dicks and balls,
but on I've seen in,
you know,
films or whatnot.
But I got to show you this,
uh,
when I found a new star for you,
strong performers.
Wait,
we have to watch this Rocco.
Suffredini I know.
Why don't we watch it?
We watch it tonight.
I'd love to.
Yeah.
I saved it because I saw it when you're gone.
I'd definitely watch it,
but I found out,
man,
she just see this guy.
What is it?
What's the story?
I just show it to you later and we can talk about it next week,
but I find a new big Dick Dangler for you.
Oh Geez.
Really given people the business too.
You're like it.
I will.
Yeah,
I'll like it.
Or You like it?
No,
I definitely like it,
but I want to show it to you.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's a porno star.
Oh boy.
I don't know if I need it in my life quite honestly.
I think you might be like,
and you know,
that was so fucking cool.
God.
People watching on Youtube.
I don't even want to repeat what you just did,
but people just listening to this show don't know how to,
I'm not even going to repeat it.
A nasty.
Did your own porno man make a porno?
Girl
saw hot.
So fun.
I love shooting
fucked up.
It's so fucked up.
Do you think those girls are,
do you think there,
there must be some girls have genuinely let love it,
love fucking bang whores and then there's some precedent telling themselves and
then their girls are so high that they're like,
what do I have to say to do this?
All of your theories are correct.
What do I have to say to make $150 today?
All of your theories are right.
Oh,
you're going to sneeze and then you're going to go,
oh,
this needs filled so good.
Ooh,
that was terrible.
That was terrible.
Oh,
I can't believe I haven't brought this up.
Yesterday you came home and,
uh,
we ordered some Thai food and I had the Panang curry and you had your yellow
curry.
Are you done?
I think so.
You've got snot in your mustache.
I feel so good.
It doesn't feel good.
I feel good right now.
I want to snooze more.
Really enjoy that.
Yeah.
Really holding up the whole show now.
Tom just go.
Nobody wants to hear it.
Um,
so we all had our curries and then like 15 minutes after you ate,
we were in the kids' playroom planning and Plato and you were like,
oh,
I just farted.
No,
it wasn't good.
That was a hot,
hot hot for it and it was real bad.
And then you went,
what is that?
What is that?
When you eat something?
Yeah,
let's talk about it.
And like within 10 minutes you can feel the water for them.
It's not what you just ate,
it's what you ate previously.
That's my theory.
No,
no,
but old shit.
What's being pushed out.
But what you just ate is triggering.
It's triggering.
It's contributing.
It's not spicy curry on top of something nasty that you had earlier.
It's not a good formula,
man.
It really,
but,
and let's do some,
let's do some detective work on,
I was terrified.
Some shirt lock work were sitting in there with brown line in the playroom.
Yeah,
and then I was like,
she lives in I,
my eyes bugged out.
I was like,
oh wow.
Because of the smell I,
because there was something there.
It was hot and I could feel my stomach going.
I clinched and I was like,
oh my God.
I went in the toilet.
It was like opening a faucet,
just a brown faucet.
Guatemalan Faucet.
It was liquid.
It was really liquid hundred percent seven.
Yeah,
and did it burn and that really,
that's what leads me to believe it's not what you just date.
It's what you ate previously.
You're right.
You just can't come out that fast,
but it's making you your,
your digestive system to going like,
Whoa,
we need to clear out this problem right now.
You took this morning,
took you about 20 minutes.
I noticed it took a long time.
It was more normal little,
a little more of a grind,
but more normal.
I was probably smelly from the curry.
I didn't really register the smell.
I can't remember.
It was,
what number was it?
This morning was probably a three s on bad.
No,
I was very small,
which I'm surprised because I had poop soup when I came off the road and I had
some curry last night or boy had had a diaper full of pellets when I woke up.
When I pellets.
What does that mean?
Hard?
Oh,
that was yesterday when I got him up from his nap.
They hard.
Oh,
they were like little balls.
he needs more fiber.
He won't eat vegetables to save his life right now.
No,
this morning's was better.
Would it look like just more of a little slop?
Yeah,
that's normal.
How do you get the toilet train the kid when they make like slops I mean is that
because there's a diaper mushing?
The person we're supposed to be getting into it right now,
by the way.
No,
but how do you train somebody who's shit is like mush?
It's like oatmeal.
Do you know what I mean?
How do I train that and then we ain't got to clean up everything.
I just don't understand because my browns don't look like that.
There's a,
those are baby browns,
you know,
his stomach,
the intestines are still developing.
I guess you just let them diarrhea and the
diarrhea.
It's just not dire normal baby shit.
Yeah.
These have softer rounds,
you know,
it's great as we've been training him on the word dump a I've been saying,
I have so excited about it's gotta take a dump.
You want to come with me?
And then of course he wants to come and sit on my lap while I take a shit.
But he likes to say Poopoo he likes poopoo cause it's easier to say,
but I'm probably better for his life for like interacting with other children
and like they adults that will be in those settings for him to say I can go
poopoo yeah,
go.
Okay.
I dump
dump.
No,
we even made the nanny laugh.
our nanny is a pretty reserved,
adorable Guatemalan lady and she's very proper.
And we even made her laugh with the dump thing.
She started laughing.
She knows that's not right.
She's like,
take a dump.
Um,
uh,
check this out.
I think this might be,
is this in St Louis tits?
Where is Saint Louis and is that in Mexico?
Is that where I'm going this week?
Mexico.
St Louis,
Mexico,
Missouri.
Where is Saint Louis?
I don't even know is again,
whereas Missouri,
it's not La Shit.
No.
Saint Louis is a no,
I know.
It's got the Arc de Triomphe,
the Arc de Triomphe,
the Golden Arches.
They're called Golden Arches.
Yeah.
Okay.
No,
that's Mcdonald's.
No.
Now you got me telling people.
Can I see the Golden Arches?
Yeah.
Saint Louis debts.
When you get this Saint Louis is basically all dedicated to Mcdonald's pick.
I want to see the Golden Arches.
Yeah.
Was He Ronald McDonald?
This is where like the headquarters of,
I watched the reg Ray Croft movie.
I know that that's not the case.
It was really cool that you were texted me like I'm watching this movie about
the Mcdonald's founder and he reminds me a lot of you,
he's such a piece of shit.
He's such a pos.
He's still some dude's wife.
He rips off the original co founders and they think of me.
Well,
he just looks like you act like you thinks like you.
That's all small stuff.
Uh,
check this out.
This is in Houston.
We have Houston pointed this out before about when people that you,
that they don't fit the way they talk basically.
Yeah.
And that's a new genre
show.
I like it.
I'm more mid shows and yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Good motherfucker right there.
Yep.
And you see it with,
you know,
there's certain that's a black guy talking.
No,
that's a white guy.
Oh,
right.
For the last week.
That's crazy.
That's not from last week.
That's from like three years and years ago.
But the pimp guy,
that's not a pimp,
but it is a white guy who talks like a pimp.
Um,
but then there's,
you know,
there's other people that you,
we've uh,
that like that,
you know,
that girl who was like,
Oh,
you know,
um,
what was her name?
I forget her name,
but she,
this might be her,
right?
Yeah.
She's like,
she's Asian,
right?
Yeah.
She's,
she's like ghetto and like,
you're like,
what
I see without them ally,
she's a bichon where I'm still cute.
Shit.
Get the fuck up Outta here.
I might live a little bit more taking time to talk.
Don't get me fucked up,
bitch.
I'm still hurting.
She and we'll fuck yo a stop
Asian.
Yeah,
that's wild,
right?
Why you don't normally hear Asian chicks talking like that and then it obviously
exists.
This is Ann Houston.
It's uh,
it's like a little convenience store.
The Asian dude is behind the counter.
It looks like all the customers are black and he's talking mad shit to one of
his customers.
So we don't know what's leading up to the shit talking.
But you,
you get the feeling that the Asian guy is justified like that.
The other guy has started something,
said something,
but it's just wild to see an Asian dude.
I think like this.
Right?
I mean that is crazy.
Not just like,
it's not that it's an Asian dude that is,
but like the,
he talks like that.
What's your bitch ass going to do?
It comes around the corner,
gets in this dude's face.
Right?
Doesn't that seem jarring when someone doesn't look like the accent that's
coming down in their mouth?
I mean,
you talk like that.
It's not that.
It's not possible,
but you're just like,
that's not good.
I am.
I even talk about it to a much lesser degree,
how people react to me when I speak Spanish and they're like,
oh,
I didn't think you'd speak.
It's like a small thing where they're like,
I mean there's obviously people look like me who speak Spanish,
but they still reacted like,
I just didn't expect that out of you.
You know?
And it's like when you hear this do talk this way and he looks like this is
crazy.
Yeah.
It's like stunning.
All right.
[inaudible] word.
I mean
that's oof man.
That is,
he's really part of the community.
If he can drop that shit,
trick ass bitch.
What'd he say?
Like do shit.
Yes,
bitch ass and go and do a goddamn thing.
This is an Asian guy.
That's an Asian dude.
Doesn't look aggressive at all.
Damn homie.
Maybe that's just what it's like to live in Houston.
You start talking like that,
I guess.
Have you ever,
if you're around that all the time,
you would definitely pick it up.
It'd be hilarious to find out his story.
That's what I want.
I want to know like did you immigrate to this country and you showed up and you
were like,
oh,
like try to figure out the culture and,
and then you just were immersed in gas station,
Houston culture and like that's you're like this is the world I grew up in.
Well definitely.
I mean if you hear English speakers like as second language and they pick that
up,
they learn it like British English.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Then you're like,
wow,
you talk all fancy.
Like you're from England,
right.
Native.
But he sounds like a native English speaker.
Right?
I don't think he sounds like no he's native,
but he's native to Houston gas station.
But I'm saying if he,
does this sound like you learned English after the underlying culturally from
this gas station like this guys,
that'd be funny.
Like where are you learning at this gas station?
That's where I learned to talk to my parents.
My mother learned English,
watching American television shows like sitcoms,
like watching Sanford and son and I'm all in the family.
So she knew like a lot of Sassy phrases and you're like,
wait,
how do you,
how do you know,
like talk to the hand.
That's all right.
The spotlight.
You boys better.
No,
you just can't come in any kind of stone with that bullshit.
Again,
that Asian dude was counting someone who's like,
that motherfucker got me fucked up.
Which is like real specific to be like for that to be part of your vernacular is
pretty,
you know,
it's,
it's like you,
you don't just like here a show once and start saying that that dude has been
immersed in this for a long time.
There's Wildman that is,
I could watch,
I would watch a,
a camera lock into this gas station on her 24 hours.
I'll just be like,
just keep playing there.
I give this guy a TV show instead of Kylie Jenner.
I watch this guy all day.
I mean,
that's some shit.
This dude,
like he got heated
right now.
It's a tough,
can
you imagine working at a gas station?
I mean,
it has to be such a dangerous job.
Uh,
you know,
late at night and also people are just most of the time coming to get fucked up.
It's not like your people are like,
they might kind of get that book.
No,
like let me get hostile cigars,
cigarettes,
liquor and beer,
liquor stores.
I mean there's no such a dangerous job.
I know at midnight on a Saturday night,
uh,
scared walking into gas stations,
you're like,
fuck,
I need to,
I need to pay for his gas.
So I used to go to the bathroom and you're like,
I need to get the fuck outta here.
I think it's a really bad idea that they sell alcohol at gas stations.
Like this is a place where you get in your car and drive.
I don't know,
it's just,
it does attract a seedier element to these places.
It shouldn't be CD.
Like why should a gas station be CD at all?
It shouldn't be,
but they all are because of cigarettes and alcohol.
That's where you get it.
Yeah.
No,
I,
there's,
I pulled in the gas stations before and thought it was so shade.
I go drive to find another one in different states in the u s don't they
separate that stuff out?
Like I know you can't always buy alcohol and grocery stores like on the east
coast.
Even in Colorado I think don't they have separate?
There's,
there's state for stores,
differing laws for counties.
So you could have a dry county and then the next county over you can buy
alcohol.
Yeah.
I don't think they should still call it gas stations and I know,
but it's big business like a lot of money.
They look a lot of money.
Um,
what do you feel about,
I guess this is a question about this,
eating it on the toilet.
As we all know,
there's a pretty popular way mh page on Facebook.
I've noticed recently there's a rise in mommy's thinking it's okay to literally
eat where they shit.
I can't believe this is absolutely horrific.
Trend is going unnoticed and widely accepted.
Do you think it's okay to eat on the toilet?
I personally believe it's the only way to get as fat as burnt Chrysler stay high
and tight.
Mommy.
Tina will always be my main mommy.
If she was my mom,
I would want to marry her.
Just like the gays Sariah or is that a funny way of saying Sarah,
what the fuck is that Sarah as a r y h a say Sarah Syria.
Sharia.
Sharia,
uh,
eat on the toilet.
What do you think Jean?
I did it when I was a little girl.
Um,
I have a vivid memory of being constipated during dinner.
Like I had to shit,
but then I also had to eat and my mother bringing me a bowl of spaghetti to eat
as I was shitting on the toilet.
Fuck what I do it now as an adult now.
I mean,
I accidentally walked in the bathroom with a mouthful of food yesterday and felt
creepy like chewing what was in my mouth to sit down and pee.
That felt gross.
I mean,
there's so much poo and I don't bring meals flakes onto the,
onto the toilet.
You know,
I have brought coffees in,
you know,
cause sometimes the coffee's making you brown.
I'm like,
oh,
just keep drinking it.
Right.
I mean,
I don't,
if I go like I'm going to have this meal or bringing in the toilet with him,
I wouldn't do that.
No,
I don't do that.
Only because there's poop everywhere.
Like the bacteria.
I don't even think like,
I just like what?
I mean why wouldn't you just go back to your food?
Like just why are you bringing it to the toilet?
It's two birds with one stone.
You're eating and shitting.
Like that's the symbiotic synergy.
Synergy.
I Dunno man.
I'm not a big support.
It's a timesaver.
I'm not gonna lie.
I like the theory of it.
I just don't think it's very hygienic.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't think you should.
I think there's a lot of poo in the air and,
and that's how you get sick.
Yeah.
I think you should just,
you should eat man.
Shit,
I'm shit than eat.
And if you have food that you want to eat and you also have to shit,
just wait.
You're going to wipe.
And then what?
Touched your bowl and then put your bowl down and then wash your hands.
So now you've,
you've [inaudible] you could be holding.
You have sandy.
Okay.
Then what do you do it?
So you put the,
okay,
let's walk through it.
I'm shitting.
I'm
eating the sandy.
Well,
first of all,
you walk in with one hand,
you lift the toilet seat up that's contaminated.
Your hands already contaminated.
It's got shit flex on it.
You know what I mean?
Like microbial shit flex.
I'm sitting down,
I'm shitting and shitting.
I'm eating,
and then,
oh,
it's time to wipe.
Now what do I do at the Sandy?
You finish it.
Well,
I'm not a fast eater like you.
I'm going to say it's half half done.
I want to put that on a dirty counter.
Was Shit flex here.
Put It on the ground.
I'm going to wipe,
wipe,
wipe.
You put it in between your feet on the ground and then you pick it up and you
finish eating so revolting.
Some people are nasty as hell.
No mother fucking hell right now.
I tell you.
So Sarah Tiana,
you know Sarah t comedian,
she and I went to Afghanistan together and we stayed in.
We stayed in Kandahar,
Afghanistan,
and in Kandahar is what's known as the poop pond,
where they put all the sewage from the base into this pond and they turn it,
it churns.
So you smell shit wafting throughout the base.
What is that?
It's the poupon of Ken Haar.
Now what happened was,
uh,
many,
many weeks later she got very,
very,
very ill with meningitis and in Atlanta,
she was in Atlanta visiting your folks.
They go where you buy it,
you know by poo anytime.
And she goes,
yeah,
I was,
I was in Kandahar about a month ago.
They go like a definitely do it to yeah,
like in the air.
That's right.
Whoa.
Just having it in.
And that's how you get things like,
like just floating in the air and people touch their hands in their mouth and
the next thing you know,
counter argument is that like maybe it'll make you stronger.
So you should do it more.
Maybe it was less than a month.
Actually,
I would say a couple of weeks after we got back,
maybe you should be doing it.
Maybe you should be eating on the toilet.
We settled it all your meals on the toilet.
And I also heard while you're potty training your kids that they get pink eye
more because they're touching their eye.
You know,
you can't look a
very full day today.
I want to say she on the toilet and I'm going to say
anything else need to add gene,
anything you'd say.
Ah,
for those of you don't know,
my Netflix special comes out October 10th,
mother inferior.
So get ready to watch that.
October 10 on net fracks.
Very exciting.
Amazing,
exciting amaze.
I just saw artwork.
I just saw a trailer.
Very excited.
It's all being worked on right now.
So the title card,
the title shows up,
but the card itself isn't up yet.
Sorry.
We thought it would be,
but they're still finalizing the artworks and it will be a very soon.
Yeah,
it's an excellent special.
Thank you guys again for listening.
Here is f a r t by Billy robot.
We will see you next week.
We have a great guest next week.
Um,
I'll,
I'll just save it,
save it.
I'll save it.
R t we watched what happened.
I watched what happened and rex at heart,
heart,
a r,F ,
a,
r,
t,
heart,
heart.
Why isn't the government talking about how to retain skilled labor?
Why is it the infrastructure ministers talking about how to implement
infrastructure funding yet construction workers back to work in Alberta.
Why does this government treat?
I'll burn out like a fart in the room that nobody wants to talk about or
acknowledge.
F A r t laughing at me
and they're laughing at you are laughing at me.
Mark,
F,
a r,
t,
heart,
heart.
Oh,
and by the way,
constituents,
when you're bored,
you're bored.
You're bored when you're bored.
Wow.
Lastly,
laughing at me.
Laughing at me.
Laughing,
laughing,
laughing at me.
You're laughing at me.
Laughing,
laughing,
laughing.
We watch what happened.
What happened?
Oh.
And by the way,
constituents,
heart,
heart.